قال نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
لان التصعيد الروسيه الاخير على البنيه
التحتيه للحبوب الاوكرانيه يظهر مواصله
موسكو منع وصول الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه
الى من هم في امس الحاجه اليها على حد
تعبيره واشار المتحدث لان واشنطن تجري
اتصالات مع الحلفاء لتامينه مسارات بديله
لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
المستمره على البنيه التحتيه للحبوب
الاوكرانيه وتدع روسيا للعوده الى مبادره
البحر الاسود للحبوب على الفور هذا
التصعيد المتواصل يظهر استمرار موسكو في
منع وصول الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه الى من
هم بامس الحاجه اليها في جميع انحاء
العالم دمرت الهجمات الروسيه الكثير من
الحبوب الاوكرانيه وسيؤدي هذا الى تفاقم
ازمه الغذاء العالميه وابقاء الاسعار
مرتفعه في غضون ذلك نحن نعمل مع شركائنا
لتحديد الخيارات المحتمله للعثور على
ممرات يمكننا من خلالها الاستمرار في نقل
الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى حيث يجب